التقى ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان بوزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن الذي يجري ثالث زياره له الى
السعوديه منذ اندلاع الحرب في قطاع غزه
وتاتي زياره بلينكن في اطار جوله اقليميه
يبحث خلالها الوزير الامريكي عده ملفات
اقليميه من بينها ملف الحرب في
غزه وقال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن انه بحث في الرياض مع ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان الجهود
المبذوله لزياده المساعدات الانسانيه
العاجله وضمان وصولها الى من يحتاجون
اليها في قطاع غزه واضاف بلينكن انه ستتم
مواصله الانخراط في الدبلوماسيه في
المنطقه لمنع المزيد من انتشار الصراع كما
اكدت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان اللقاء بحث
الحاجه الملحه للحد من التوترات الاقليميه
بما فيها وقف هجمات جماعه انصار
الله